Nicholas now that crowdfunding has been
around for a little bit and what people
are familiar with it is there a dark
side that's developed I think there is a
dark side you know as with everything
but I can't say I've experienced it or
at least not yet the I mean the only
dark side for us was that it's being
really really difficult and a pain in
the ass to be trying to find money for
three years and a half because we are
filmmakers and we love to do films not
to find money so it's it's difficult
because we turn out to be executive
producers looking for money not on the
studios or or you know wealthy people
but on you know these people names and I
asking them for five bucks or two bucks
or whatever so it's been it's been
difficult but at the same time we
learned like a lot and we were able
coming we were able to get the money
shoot the film we wanted to make with
the money we needed to have complete
freedom to for example because it was a
need to be editing the film for seven
months which is something only not a
single producer will allow you to do and
in the end to distribute the way we want
so I don't think I'm going to have a
chance like this in my whole life again
like having complete freedom as a
director writer and producer to do the
film i wanted to do so if there is a
dark side attached to grow up on them i
come speak about it and i'm sure there
is very not being easy but we were lucky
what about people being overconfident
especially in their amounts that they're
trying for there's been so many great
projects and there's six-figure projects
and so
when people see that and maybe feel a
little misled by it or not feel a little
misled but than they are misled because
then they try to see that lately I said
it is funny that I talked about this
since our budget was 160 thousand euros
which is more than a million dollars um
you know right now that that we achieved
it and that we got to make the film with
that but I wouldn't recommend anyone to
try to get the amount of money through
crowdfunding that's my advice I mean if
I talk to myself three years ago you
know I was I was confident enough and
and we had chipped it but I wouldn't
recommend it it's really difficult and I
don't think rectum is is ready yet for
that kind of months I think for short
films and books and albums and any other
thing that is below thirty thousand it's
great over that you're gonna have a hard
time you might be lucky but you know one
of one out of a thousand is gonna be
successful and rest gonna fail so maybe
it's smarter to just start smaller and
get the part to make a trailer or I
don't know to you know build it again
build a community before then get some
money from a different place and then I
don't know I mean there's a million
things today most of the projects that
are asking for a lot of money they are
being a failure
you